there's no you in Ukraine that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
there's a song blowing up in the
Internet by a young man named Oliver
Anthony it's called Richmond north of
Richmond and is best described as raw
blue-collar country
lord it's a damn shame what the world's
gotten to for people like me people like
you wish I could just wake up and not be
true but it is
all it is
I'll talk more about why that song is
resonating now a little bit later in the
show but it speaks to what millions of
Americans are feeling these days
despondent and left behind
now while May some may have voted for
Biden on the assumption that he cared
about people like them many are seeing
that his home spun grandfatherly
demeanor is all an act
after 18 months in office it's obvious
he doesn't really care at all
unless perhaps you live in Ukraine
we will not waver we will not waver
I mean that our commitment to Ukraine
will not weaken we will stand for
Liberty and freedom today tomorrow and
for as long as it takes
has he ever sounded that excited about
doing anything good for the American
people all right and just yesterday
Biden asked Congress for a staggering 24
billion dollars more in Ukraine Aid now
this is on top of the more than 100
billion we've already sent over any
humanitarian and Military assistance
now in case you've forgotten America is
broke
and we have massive problems of Our Own
just look at our cities and Decay and
despair
and now the horrendous wildflowers fires
in Maui
now no wonder Americans support for
Ukraine is declining
but are the politicians even listening
if you think the United States should be
supporting Ukraine in the fight against
Putin
raise your hand
nobody you don't have to be that smart
to put the
connect the dots right and so our is the
war to cover up
sins committed so you can cover your
cracks
there's too much money that's been
thrown over there
55 percent of Americans say congress
should not authorize additional funding
to support Ukraine now compare that to
back in February 2022 when 62 percent
said they felt like we should have been
doing more
but our brilliant Administration
believes Americans get why Ukraine
matters
I think the American people understand
what's at stake here they know it's not
just about Ukrainian sovereignty or
Ukrainian lives it's about Mr Putin and
stopping him in his tracks before he can
go any further I think we can all
understand that if he just gets Ukraine
if he gets if he gets what he wants and
he pulls Ukraine back into Russia where
does it stop and the cost in Blood and
treasure to the American people to our
to our Financial Health obviously would
be greater much greater at risk
oh my God I wouldn't buy a gallon of
milk from that guy
that's the old nonsense we heard during
Iraq in Afghanistan if we don't fight
them over there we'll have to fight him
over here
well the real problem is is Reagan
understood we can't have peace if we
don't have economic strength peace
through strength
and the longer this drags on the weaker
the U.S will become
now we hate what's happened to the
Ukrainian people but the spring turned
summer offensive is not going too well
the generals once again seem to have
botched another assessment as Ukraine
appears stalled out right now
Vox did a sober assessment of where
things stand in the war and here are
some of their highlights
Kiev is facing logistical and Supply
challenges the country's struggling to
conduct combined arms operations
20 percent of Western Equipment was
destroyed or damaged in the early weeks
of the offensive and they're burning
through a lot of ammo
and they're running out of time to wear
Russia down with the unofficial deadline
quickly approaching of this fall
and of course Russia has major
advantages of its own in artillery and
Aviation specifically attack helicopters
of course zelinski's answer to all this
is to demand more money from you
well the United States
Europe is providing a pittance compared
to what the United States is giving in
Ukraine
but I thought the war was critical for
Europe's defense right
remember we're still carrying the Lion's
Share of the burden for Europe's
security and it's obscene considering
World War II ended 78 years ago
and as we continue to shovel billions to
Ukraine nearly four in 10 Americans
report that they don't have the funds
saved to cover even a 400 emergency
expense they might incur that's
disturbing
and Joe Biden doesn't care
no wonder his approval rating on the
economy is stuck in the mid 30s right
now
and it's not just Ukraine that's flush
with our cash by the way Iran will be
too as well now that Biden is making a
six billion dollar deal with Iran on the
promise that jailed Americans will get
to come home someday
but what's six billion dollars really
between enemies
that brings us to another infuriating
story and yet another rat hole
Afghanistan
now how many of you know that the
special Inspector General on Afghanistan
reconstruction says that he cannot
guarantee that the bulk of U.S
humanitarian Aid there is not going to
the Taliban
no but don't worry it's only eight
billion dollars
and how is it that the Democrats and
pro-war Republicans are so emotionally
pumped about protecting Ukraine's border
that they're blissfully unconcerned
about our own
Biden's allowed more than five and a
half million illegals to cross our open
border and that doesn't count the
godaways
remember back in 2018 Trump requested a
mere five billion dollars to fund a wall
along our Southern border that's about a
fifth of Biden's latest Aid request to
Ukraine one-fifth of one request
and think of what the return on
investment Americans would have seen
from that wall
but again America is not the Biden Focus
the global order is the Biden Focus
in the Biden team does not care if
you're worse off than you were in 2019
before the pandemic
Biden let the truth slip out yesterday
didn't he when discussing his signature
legislation
saying that I wish I hadn't called it
the inflation reduction act because it
has less to do with inflation than it
does providing alternatives to economic
growth
okay to the extent that Biden is
ventriloquists focus on Americans at all
it's in devising new ways to control and
limit our behavior and speech certainly
not our economic prosperity
when they say they're here to help that
doesn't mean making us richer more
prosperous safer our cities better our
borders secure
stuff like that would actually make our
lives better they're not interested in
it they Reserve their emotion and their
efforts to really help people for their
globalist goals nation building climate
commitments and foreign entanglements
with no real endpoints
if voters want to change this Dynamic
and I know you do
you're going to have to set aside your
frustrations and vote for candidates who
put America first it's about time
after all there's no you in Ukraine and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else